[Music]
all right people
we are live it's the friday before the
election
can you believe it we're almost there
this is the last weekend you'll have
before the apocalypse so enjoy it folks
get out there
go camping eat some good food go dancing
drink smoke
whatever you do this is the weekend to
do it because the zombie invasion
starts at about 8 p.m eastern
on tuesday night and then we don't know
what'll happen after that i actually did
stock up on ammunition yesterday i saw
this ridiculous story did you see this
that walmart stopped the sale of guns
and ammo
because they're afraid that the looters
are gonna break into the stores and
steal the guns in ammo
i mean the level of insanity that we're
dealing with right now
is is actually off the charts like you
can't make this up idiocracy too we're
in it
like people buy guns and ammo so that
they can protect themselves that isn't
to say bad people don't buy guns
but the guy who's buying the gun right
now at walmart or at the gun shop or
whatever
is buying it most likely to protect his
family to protect his property et cetera
et cetera he's going to walmart buying
it legally
he's the he's not the guy that's buying
the gun at walmart
to then run out run around and loot and
shoot people
and the rest of it those guns are
already out there so walmart is
literally actively stopping people
from being able to protect themselves
also we're seeing all sorts of
uh videos and pictures from from across
the country actually new york city dc
seattle portland everywhere everyone's
boarding up stores again
and it has that feeling of remember a
few days before
all the rioting started happening way
back when it seems like a lifetime ago
only four months ago or so because of
george floyd um there was like a two-day
window where suddenly everything was
being boarded
up and it was like well wait a minute if
we know this is about to happen then why
are we letting it happen shouldn't we
maybe be a little more proactive about
stopping some of this stuff
so we seem we seem to kind of be in that
situation again
uh anyway so what we're doing today you
know normally i do the direct messages
tuesday wednesday thursday we did we did
monday this week as well and i i sense
for the
foreseeable future we may be shifting to
five days a week because
i know that a little bit a little bit of
sanity is needed these days
uh i don't know by me doing more shows
if that provides my team with a little
more sanity that's
up for debate but we'll deal with that
internally we have a system and a
process from that sort of thing
anyway i want to do a live q a today
so we've already got about 30 40
questions from reubenreport.com members
if you want to jump on the reuben report
community right now you can still submit
questions and they can get them to me
while we're here i'm going to try to
plow through
as many as possible and not be too
winded obviously there's a lot about the
election
but i do want to do two quick things
before we start because there were there
were two videos that i
saw this morning that i was just like
all right these are the types of things
that people need to see to sort of show
you the media level of crazy and then
the political
level of crazy oh and by the way guys
i'm wearing a flannel again today it's
friday
and you know when i wore a flannel the
other day when we did that impromptu
thing and i had my cap on and everything
people were people were very excited
they loved it they loved lumberjack dave
a lot of people wanted me to grow out
the beard a little bit more but they
loved the flannel dave it's a little
cool here in la
and i thought you know what dave that's
i say to myself dave what are you gonna
do
you're gonna give the people what they
want so here you go it's flannel dave
again
okay uh so this first video this is
cnn's don lemon
and he was talking to chris cuomo who's
just the worst it's it's hard to figure
out who's the worst at cnn but
i've uh i've done the math we uh we
charted it all out a squared plus b
squared
equals cnn is stupid and uh
i would say chromos the worst but lemon
lemon's pretty close
uh and this one's a little personal for
me so let's take a look this is don
lemon talking to chris cuomo about why
he's got to get rid of friends
who are those nasty trump supporters
look at what's happening to them we have
to help them they're all getting killed
by this now it's happening here
yeah it's happening here right now at
his own damn rally
you know what the sad thing is and i'll
be honest with you
um i have met i have many people who i
love
in my life and yeah i come from a red
state i've lived in several red states
there are a lot of friends who i had to
really get rid of because they
they are so nonsensical when it comes to
this issue they have the whole every
single talking point that they hear on
state tv
and that they hear from this president
they repeat it and they are blinded by
it
and i just came when i said to you the
other night there's no way they can't
believe it they can't you know
i was just goosing you in a way right
you know they say i was you know
um because i was breaking your you know
your boosting works
it's not like that'll be all over the
world so but here's the thing
um i i had to get rid of them because
they are too far gone i try and i try
and i try
they'll say something really stupid and
then i'll show them the science and i'll
give them
the information and they still repeat
those talking points
and all the while the state
was a hot spot many if you look at the
information that we put up last night
that came up yesterday showed you
how the red states have now taken over
where the blue states where people came
in because there are
bigger cities and there's more
transmission obviously where where there
are
more people are closer together and so
now the red states are the problem
and i just i had to get rid of a lot of
people in my life because
sometimes you just have to let them go i
think that they have to hit rock bottom
like an addict
right and they have to want to get help
they have to want to know the truth they
have to want to live in reality they
have to want to be responsible
not only for other people's lives but
for their lives so you know what i have
had it's so sad
and i don't know if after this i will
ever be able to go back and be friends
with those people because
at a certain point you just say they're
too far gone
and i got to let them go and if they're
willing to come back and if they're real
willing to live in in reality
then i welcome them with open arms but i
can't do it and i can't do it anymore
all right so first off i apologize for
subjecting you to two minutes of cnn so
you know that one it's on me folks i
apologize for that um there's a lot
there first off
uh he referred to state tv the
implication that you're getting a lot of
stuff that's pro-trump from state tv
i don't know what could possibly be
closer to state tv
than cnn but all right let's put that
aside because that's obviously not what
this
is really about uh this this idea of
dropping
friends that you have to drop friends
over
politics he says specifically that he
got rid of a lot of people
they have to hit rock bottom like an
attic now
i've talked about this a lot and it's
it's in my book of course that you
should actually do
everything possible in your life
and everything that is manageable
without selling yourself
out to make sure that you don't lose
friends over politics
but what don just showed there is what
is so consistent with the lefty thinking
which is
if you're not with me you're against me
and that you're somehow an addict and
you're crazy and you have to hit rock
bottom and you're awful
and all of those things you're
deplorable
and that is very much a difference of
what i would say is the modern lefty
mind than
than the modern mind of someone on the
right the righty mind let's say
and the reason for that is that people
on the right generally don't think that
politics is the end-all be-all of
everything and that what you
every little political decision you make
is gonna kill
you or kill someone else or something
like that and this is seriously
dangerous by the way these are the very
people i mean cuomo and lemon and these
lefties these are the people who would
say that they're the tolerant ones
but in essence what he's saying there is
he's the least tolerant person right
like how could you be less tolerant than
saying to friends
i'm not going to be friends with you
anymore because of your political
beliefs as opposed to saying we have
differences of opinion but
perhaps i know you're a good person
that's why we were friends in the first
place
and let's try to work it out by the way
i have had many friends dropped me over
the last couple years i've had
acquaintances drop me i've had
issues with family members all because
i'm just saying what i believe now
for those of you guys that watch this
you know i'm not saying anything hateful
but if if your side has run around
calling everyone nazis
uh for five years well then you might
start thinking that people are actual
nazis and then you won't listen to
measured people so that's why someone
like me is thought of as as too
dangerous
at some level which as anyone watching
this you know that that's just complete
complete nonsense i will just add in one
other thing here which is that don lemon
and i used to be friends
we were friends um so i take no great
pleasure in this but we hung out in
atlanta we hung out in new york city we
went to bars we went to dinner a couple
times
and then one day about two years ago or
so i just noticed he unfollowed me on
twitter there was no
oh dave i think you're getting this
wrong or any private exchange of
anything i've never mentioned this
publicly before and i don't really
i don't really care i mean i have plenty
of friends you know i mean i think i
said it
on the show yesterday i mean one of the
things that i think has kept me grounded
through all of this and the hate and
losing friends and whatever it might be
is hey
when you start standing up for what you
believe in you find all sorts of new
friends so i have plenty of
new friends but also my my two best
friends to this day
are my buddy john who i met the first
day of kindergarten i remember meeting
him
and so we were like four or five years
old we've been friends for 40 years
right so that kind of keeps me grounded
and my other good friend is
is my buddy arie who moved to town when
we were in third grade and now 35 years
later
uh we're still good friends and they're
not political in any way
other than they care about at a cursory
level and they're sort of interested in
what i do and that sort of stuff but
like it doesn't dictate our
our friendship by any stretch and
there's regardless of who they voted for
it would not be a referendum on our
friendship i think you guys know that
in your own life and and this is one of
the things when i say that
those of us who are not woke right like
if you're awake and not woke
one of the little things we can do is
just be a little bit better
and i think if you just watch that don
lemon clip you would understand it's not
that hard to be a little bit better than
these guys
all right i want to throw to one other
clip and then i promise i'll get to the
questions and i'll do it
in a quicker fashion uh this is joe
biden yesterday
giving a speech we're just going to play
about a minute of it here because
there's so many wrong things that he
says here
but also we tried to count try to count
the amount of times while he's reading
off a teleprompter
that he slurs his words now i'm not
saying
that is or isn't anything specific and
sometimes reading a teleprompter
can be difficult and everything else but
just catch that
if if nothing else but then also listen
to some of the over top rhetoric all
right here we go
we needed to vote for the legacy of ruth
bader ginsburg
she was proof that courage
conviction and moral clarity
can change the world without being
vicious and mean
she and justice scalia disagreed on
everything but they were friends
they disagreed we got to get back to
that
politics has become so ugly and mean and
disruptive
but we can be the voices for justice in
her name
we have to make our voices heard you
have to vote you have to vote because
while donald trump
fails to condemn white supremacy we can
deliver on racial justice
donald trump he doesn't believe there's
any such thing as systemic
racism has a problem he won't even say
black lives matter well you know and i
know black lives do matter and so do
others
that's why this season of protest has
broken out all across the nation
god there's just so much dribble there
joe okay put it putting the slur stuff
aside it doesn't matter
he says politics has been ugly and mean
two sentences later he says that donald
trump won't condemn white supremacists
which we know he has done
a million times and we know that joe
biden has lied about this a million
times and we know that you're allowed to
lie about
very fine people on both sides on
twitter and they're not going to take
your twitter account down
um this is just oh oh in this he won't
say black lives matter
black lives matter we've been through
this a million times joe joey
if you're watching uh black lives matter
the organization is a marxist
organization that is in cahoots with all
of the people that are burning down the
cities that in many ways are the base of
your party
donald trump believes that black lives
matter in that black people should have
equality
like everybody else right that obviously
is what he believes
and by the way that's why black people
are going to vote in the highest numbers
ever
for donald trump that's why candace
owens has done something imagi
unimaginable with with blexit and
and all of the things that we see
actually happening on the
on the streets but then he gets into the
fight and gets into the systemic racism
stuff
and it's just like just because you say
it but this is what they do with
everything just because you say it
doesn't mean it's true
there are no laws stopping black people
from doing anything meaning that the
system itself is racist
that doesn't mean we couldn't put more
money into certain communities as far as
education or we could change certain
things on the margins of course we could
but this idea that the system joe if the
system
is racist if the system is wrong and
everything else well you've been in it
for 47 years what did you and your buddy
barack do
apparently nothing so why would anyone
vote for your old bones it doesn't make
any sense oh it's just it's just
annoying okay people let's get to q a
and i promise to do it a little bit
quicker
then everything else i've done today and
in general
uh emily asks what will you do as a
california resident if there's a blue
wave or as the internet is calling it
hashtag bluemaga
i haven't heard of hashtag bluemaga i
don't sense that we'll pick up
if there's a blue wave well i really
don't think that there will be
i i just don't maybe i'm wrong people
and maybe the people that hate me will
clip this video on wednesday
and prove me wrong but i i just sense
that the base that voted for trump last
time there's just no reason they
wouldn't vote for him this time maybe a
tiny bit of people
they're not happy with some covid stuff
or something but the base is there
the enthusiasm is there the rallies are
there everything else
and then when you take all of the middle
people
or some of the conservatives even who
didn't vote for trump last time
and people that i meet in los angeles i
met
we have friends who is one of the couple
the male and the couple
is an extremely well-known comedy writer
and he is a huge closet trump supporter
after being a bernie supporter and the
reason is because they forced him to do
this diversity nonsense in his writing
room
okay meaning that instead of hiring who
the funniest people are to write a
comedy show
he had to hire one black person one
trans person one gay person one indian
blah blah
nobody's against those people having
jobs or being in the world of comedy
but he said nothing was funny because
all they talked about was how everything
was offensive in every writer's room
that's the river it's the death of
comedy actually
um so i see i see a lot of you know sort
of the ex-lefties
that will vote for trump um but then
also you know i've mentioned glenn beck
did not vote for trump
last time right he is a big voice in the
conservative movement so he represents a
certain amount of people
ben shapiro is probably the biggest sort
of young conservative voice and he did
not vote for donald trump last time he
is
voting for donald trump uh austin
peterson
who was almost the libertarian
presidential candidate last time
uh he did not vote for trump last time
he is voting for trump i just saw
literally right before we started
clay travis from outkick who did not
vote for trump last time he's voting for
trump this time
that guy dave rubin who did not vote for
trump last time is voting for trump this
time
so something has happened and if you
think that is going to be reflected in
the polls
uh as scott adams often says there's
probably a certain amount of people
who are just messing with the pollsters
because they hate the pollsters and they
hate the media
by the way i i've been asking friends
when
we have people over for dinner sometimes
i know gavin duson probably
is going to try to come for me for that
but we do have people over we let them
sit wherever they want sometimes we sing
songs
um and i ask people i've been asking
people for weeks months probably
have you ever been polled i've had only
one person out of probably 50 people in
my life that i've asked about this one
person say yes
they said they got a landline call about
10 years ago so who the hell are they
polling
they were all wrong last time the idea
that they're going to be right this time
i just don't buy it
i don't see any enthusiasm for biden i
see a lot of enthusiasm
for trump and i see a lot of people that
either voted third party someone like me
or didn't vote at all just saying enough
of this leftist lunacy i like america
i'm sick of all this and and there's
only one guy that's gonna
even try to stop it otherwise you know
they'll bring critical race theory back
we'll get title nine back
joe will spend four years from the
bunker well it won't be joe but they'll
be telling you about systemic races and
systemic racism and everything else so
it's up to you people it's up to you
whatever you want all right that's that
one
um let's see since trump gave you a
shout
out are you still gay trump gave me a
shout out yesterday
after my appearance on fox and friends
super early in the morning
uh and then somebody was some idiot was
tweeting that i'm a grifter and if i was
only given enough money i would not be
gay anymore so i tweeted
that you know that all they got all they
got basically is calling everyone a
racist and a grifter but i said you know
what i'll play your game here and if you
start a gofundme
and it gets to a million bucks i'll bang
a chick um i don't know that anyone
started the gofundme so it was a little
it was a little unclear although i did
have an awful lot of girls
offering to do it for free so that that
that's always nice and that shows that
that
there's a warmth to the people on the
right that just doesn't exist
with the people on the left you know
what i mean um what are the odds of
maxine waters and adam schiff living
losing their seats so i pray that both
of them do
maxine waters who has been the
representative from south central l.a
for 44 years she does not live in south
central
l.a she lives in hancock park which is a
super elite expensive area in a six
million dollar mansion
as south central l.a crumbles i had joe
collins on who is the
the young man navy vet happens to be a
black man
running against and grew up obviously in
south central lives there
uh he's running against maxine waters if
you didn't see the interview we put it
up
last saturday so you can check that out
his name's joe collins and he had a
fantastic ad much like that
that kim klasik ad from baltimore uh so
i hope it happens but you know beating
these lifetime politicians and kicking
them out of the machine is is tough
uh as for adam schiff well i voted for
eric early the republican candidate and
i hope schiff gets booted
and uh you know even even bill maher a
couple weeks ago had adam schiff on and
he was like
all my friends are leaving the taxes are
high the state's crumbling uh what's the
problem here
and shift sort of just sat there you
know he's got those bug eyes and he
really had nothing to say about it
now the next step would be bill maher
realizing that he keeps voting in and
supporting candidates that are actually
burning his own state
but one thing at a time here uh how did
you go about starting your tech company
locals so for those of you that don't
know what locals is real quick
we decided to give tools to creators so
that you wouldn't have to rely on big
tech so those of you that are part of
the reubenreport.com community
we've got a news feed we've got video
player audio player you can communicate
directly with me and you can comment and
you can like
uh there are push notifications so i can
directly get in touch with
people and if i was to be booted off all
the big tech stuff which who knows what
will happen i mean biden becomes
president and then
the crazed left and big tech are now
even stronger why wouldn't they just
boot everybody off
right shut down shut down the droids
execute order 66 why not
um so we thought let's give tools to
creators
to to save themselves to own their stuff
we don't own it
it's their content we're just giving you
the tools to build whatever house you
want to build
and that's how we built reuben report
community and then i went around and i
started talking to some other creators
and we've gotten
a ton of great people on there obviously
scott adams is on there and
greg gutfeld and carlin borsenko and
bridget fetishi and michael malus and
all sorts of people but anyone can be on
there of any political persuasion just
don't break the laws of the united
states and it's your community
and if people come in and you don't want
them there then boot them out just like
you don't invite everybody
your own house we're not trying to
replace big tech we're just trying to
protect people
from big tech but to specifically answer
your question how do i go about starting
it
i had the idea i started you know i'm
fortunate enough because of what i do
here that i that i know some people i
started talking
to some people in silicon valley
although i didn't really fully want to
go that route because obviously they
have a woke problem there and they've
created a lot of the problem
but i started talking to some people
with some money and we we raised some
money
and we're probably about to go into
series a in in a couple weeks
but the company is blowing up absolutely
blowing up we've hired a lot of people
right out of the reuben report community
which has been great
and uh we've got offices in ukraine
don't
tell adam schiff don't tell maxine
wardens uh but
it's really blowing up and i'm very
proud of what we've done and if you
haven't seen what we've done
go to reubenreport.com or you can
download the locals app and you can find
all the communities that are out there
and it'll be a way of me
being always able to communicate with
you regardless of what big tech does
to me um oh this is a good one why do
you think there aren't more classical
liberals fighting against the crazy
lefties
um fear fear it's it really is that
simple
i know a lot of people and i'm talking
about people that you know
blue czech people perhaps people that
have been on this
show who are pub privately right now
they're supporting trump in their own
little world or at least
you know in what they'll say in private
conversation but refuse to do it
publicly because of the cost i actually
got a message
this morning from someone that i really
really respect someone i i have on the
show i've had on the show
uh more than once who i consider a good
decent tolerant moral person and they
actually wrote to me that they think i'm
making the wrong choice by supporting
trump but that
me being brave is probably a bigger more
complimentary
uh comment at the moment because so few
people are being brave i don't know if
i'm being brave or stupid i just thought
in america you just say what you think
i really thought that's what it was i
actually still think it is what it is
and that more and more people are gonna
do it but i think the classical liberals
i think in essence the two things that
sort of stopped classical liberals i
think
on the road from leaving crazy leftism
because everyone sees it now everyone
sees it
there were two things that that sort of
stopped them from sort of going full
conservative at this point or full trump
or something like that
and i think it's abortion and religion
they just have like this this
real aversion to both and i've tried to
have honest conversations about abortion
i've tried to have honest conversations
about religion and i don't
fear being around people that i disagree
with and i think for a lot of the
the classical liberals the old school
liberals
they're so obsessed with with still
being liked by people who would just as
easily destroy them you know i mentioned
the other day there was this
public letter written by i think 17
public intellectuals you know all sort
of liberal types the stephen pinker crew
again i've had him on the show i think
he's a decent guy and they're all saying
that
that voting for trump is wrong and it's
like guys trump is the one that's
actually saving the institutions that
that you care about it doesn't mean that
trump is perfect and it doesn't mean
that we'll present other problems five
years down the road but i don't want to
be shot today
i'd rather think about how do we move
forward we'll deal with some of that in
five years
so i think they're very short-sighted i
think they they want to go to
comfortable parties and be thought of
as the nice tolerant decent people but i
think that the rubber has met the road
and if you can't figure out which way to
go at this point if you're a public
person and you can't tell people what
you think at this point it's not because
it's not because the right is stopping
you obviously it's because the left is
stopping you so it's on you
uh do you have any thoughts about the
recent events in france and do you think
there's any sensible solution
so you know this is barely being
reported in the united states but there
have been a couple beheadings
one at a church in france and now uh you
know there's
macron who's the prime minister is
basically trying to speak up a bit
about islamism and jihadism
and the rest of it stuff that we've sort
of stopped talking about here for a
while
but that europe has has a separate
problem with because in america we've
done the melting pot thing much better
and we've brought people here and
they've folded into
american society much better than in all
parts of europe but france has a
particular problem with this
and and by the way all the jews are
leaving france and they're all going to
israel so when i was
in israel last time about four or five
years ago uh
every other corner that you go to in tel
aviv is now like a french bakery
basically
um so they have all sorts of problems
there um
will they actually stand up and stop
this stuff you know this all
sort of started or at least was really
put on the map um
when when the charlie hebdo the the
satirical magazine where their offices
were stormed by jihadists
and a bunch of cartoonists and satirists
were killed
and the left sort of most people on the
left were kind of like oh don't poke the
bear don't draw those cartoons
and it's like this sort of this is the
soft bigotry of low expectations oh if
we do something these people don't like
they're
they're entitled or they have should
have some reason to kill us
this is what something that the west is
going to have to deal with and i don't
think there are any easy answers but the
more that you placate it
the worse that it eventually will be but
i also think that this is it sort of
gets to the earlier question about the
classical liberals
there's a certain type of liberal
thinker i think that thinks
if you're just sort of nice enough to
people that eventually they'll come
around
and i just don't think that's a
realistic way of looking at the world
when people say they want to kill you
when they want to change your way of
life when they want to change the system
you should listen to them
because they're probably telling you the
truth and yes you will be
beheaded a little bit later than the guy
who's speaking out against it but
rest assured your beheading is on the
way all right i'm not doing this fast
enough
um how do you think hovered restrictions
and coveted life in general will be
after the election
i mean look if trump wins i think they
will trump will feel emboldened enough
to be more outwardly telling the states
what to do i
would still leave it to the states but i
think a trump win might
rile up enough people in each state even
in a place like california where we will
just stop
listening to this buffoon that is gavin
newsom where in new york
they'll stop listening to andrew cuomo
who sent all of those people back
into the old age homes and killed them
and then wrote a book
dared to write a book which he obviously
didn't write but dared to write a book
about leadership in the in the time of a
pandemic that i mean these people are
just absolute clowns
um so i think if trump wins there will
be a real push to open things up
realize that it's on you as a business
owner to decide what you want to do with
your business
you as an individual to decide what you
want to do as a store owner shop owner
etc etc
whether you want to send your kids to to
baseball practice after school all of
those things like
let's get it back to the people that
would be the obvious answer trump wins
if biden wins i mean a well either
suddenly all the states will
be like oh we can open up because joe
joe's taking good care of us because at
some level obviously they've wanted to
tank the economy to hurt
trump i mean that's just that's just
real that's just it's not not real
people
um so i think there could be some of
that but at the same time biden has
been using the fear about this thing we
need a federal mass mandate
and you know you hear these people we're
going to shut down until 2022.
again has your life been more affected
by the virus or the lockdowns and in
almost every case
it's the lockdowns and the destruction
of the economy and personal lives
and keeping people in their houses and
rates of suicide that are up and
secondary diseases that people are
getting because they're not being
checked for diseases because they're not
going to the doctor as often i went for
my freaking teeth cleaning they don't
even polish your teeth anymore i had the
full teeth cleaning
and then they were like oh we don't
polish anymore because it could spray
some
stuff around it's like you got a mask
and another thing and a shield
and now so i got my teeth cleaned you
know that's the nice you know when you
leave a
teeth cleaning and you're like oh man
that's good that's good it's like a
bowling alley
yeah no i left the teeth out cleaning i
was like
didn't really do much okay couple more
real quick what are you having for
thanksgiving how many people will be
there too
so this is obviously in reference to the
other day gavin newsom put these
ridiculous regulations on thanksgiving
again
15 days to flatten the curve that's what
they were telling us in march
now they're giving us regulations for a
month from now
into november you think there's a
problem there people are you tracking
this
i'm not a mathemagician but i think the
uh the numbers here aren't adding up
um i we uh thanksgiving is the holiday
that we host
uh for our family we're gonna host as
many people as possible i am going to do
it how i want to do it we're going to
make a big ass
turkey and we're going to have some
serious stuffing and a lot of great wine
and and if i can't get all my family
here maybe i'll have fans here i don't
know
we'll figure out something but i'm
certainly he doesn't want you to sing no
singing and you have to have it outside
like you don't own me
what what gives you the right you have
no right
you freaks i said i called him a freak
yesterday a lot of people like that so
he is a freak
okay let's back up real quick um
[Music]
if you could change one and one thing
and only one thing in 20
20. what would you change if anything
well i mean look this is cliche for me
to say at this point but i would want
more people to realize the poison that
is identity politics
the main driving force now between what
the media and the democratic
establishment and the cultural
establishment is pushing on us
is not only toxic but it is a parasite
that is eating the host
the united states is the host and we
have had a healthy body for 250 years
that at times hasn't been perfect and is
certainly not perfect now
but it's been a pretty good host to all
of us
and we're watching an idea spread
as if it's tolerant and as if it's
diverse and good
and it's eating away at the fabric of
society and we need more and more people
to wake up to it and in many ways i
think the election is a referendum on
that
more than whether it's a referendum on
trump or biden do you fundamentally
think this thing is good and should we
continue with it and that
oddly would leave you voting for trump
or do you think somehow we have to
really really change it and the guy
who's going to change it is the guy
who's been around for 47 years as i keep
saying it none of it makes
any sense so so the wake up to how toxic
this ideology is how it is the true
antithesis of everything that
is american that's what i would have
loved to have changed in 2020 i think i
i did the best i could do um oh uh let
let's do two or three more real quick
uh i like this one uh off politics do
you believe in spirits
not ghosts or angels in other words do
you believe that once someone you love
has passed that their spirit can
communicate with you
and you with him or her albeit not the
traditional sense of communicate
so i'm going to tell you a ghost story
so i've had one experience that i could
only chalk up to a ghost story i don't
know what the hell happened
in reality but i will tell you one ghost
story and then i'll tell you one story
on
on belief and the rest of it i was at my
buddy my buddy john who i mentioned
earlier i was at his house
and he lives in a house sort of an old
uh
you know couple story but like old
victorian kind of house like sort of you
know has like
the hallmarks of it could be in like a
like a horror type movie
i love you john this is not a con the
house is great house you know what i'm
saying
it's an older house right and you've
done great things with it um
but anyway i was sleeping at his house
once probably about 10 years ago
and emma our old dog was was still alive
she was sleeping on the floor i'm
sleeping in the bed and
i'm in the guest room and his girlfriend
at the time had a
uh had a vanity at the end of the bed
you know there was a desk and a vanity
with like a mirror
where she does her makeup basically i
woke up in the middle of the night
i'm not kidding you know i i'm doing one
of these i'm waking up and i look in the
mirror
in the vanity and i saw an old woman
combing her hair i can remember the
brush it was like one of those bulbous
brushes at the end
and this old woman is just combing her
hair in the mirror and i like
freaked out clyde jumped into the bed
his hair
uh her hair was standing up on on the
back you know when the dogs were all
freaked out
and then the woman looked at me and then
and then i kind of freaked and she
disappeared
i don't know what the hell that was was
it a ghost uh
you know did i drink too much like i
don't know but
i can tell you that that experience like
that is a real experience in my world
i know people have had all sorts of
other other strange experiences um
as far as uh spirits um
believe in do i believe in spirits
i believe that there are all sorts of
things about the human psyche that
that we don't quite understand and i've
had people
that are very close to me i had a good
childhood friend who was killed in a
motorcycle accident
um and a day or two after he died i had
this incredible
dream where i was in a in a limo with
him and he looked like a million bucks
and he
he died in a pretty horrific motorcycle
accident
he looked like a million bucks he was
wearing this really sharp suit
and we were sitting there and he had
this big smile on his face
um and i was saying something like you
know josh what's going on he's like
everything's great man everything's
great
and he just looked amazing look kind of
big sort of like bit larger than life
and and he just opened the door to the
limo and got out and i couldn't see
anything out there not that it was a
white light but i just couldn't really
see where he was going
now maybe that's my it's the mind
exercising oh you just lost a friend
with the mind has to like negotiate how
to like move forward in life when
someone
is tragically ripped away too young
maybe that is some message from
something like
this is one of those things where i'm
i'm open to these discussions
which is why i can talk to eckhart tolle
about spirituality the same way i can
talk to
sam harris from an atheist perspective
or
uh robbie zacharias from uh from a
christian perspective i i think there's
something that that
everyone can offer in this arena there's
a little something for you that was uh
away from politics a bit and uh let's
just knock out one more
here um oh what is your favorite part
from the mandalorian so far and what are
you looking forward to
in the new season so you guys know my
feelings the the
last three star wars i loved force
awakens
and then uh last jedi was just a
disaster and then the rise of skywalker
was just cleaning up the mess and they
actually did a pretty decent job of it
but you know they've even admitted now
that they didn't know what the arc of
the story was and they were just piecing
together
this whole thing and it sort of loses
any sort of cohesive thing and you know
oh he's you know she's the granddaughter
and blah blah blah it's all just like oh
we just wrote anything to sort of make
everybody kind of feel good and whatever
so
so star wars has been sort of tainted on
me although i can still go back to
prequels and the originals
and love them and i keep telling you the
prequels are looking better and better
as time goes on
the mandalorian i liked it i did not
love it i need i need a little more
i need some jedi i need a lightsaber too
i sense there may be a lightsaber or two
i've tried to avoid the spoilers online
but i think maybe a lightsaber two's
gonna get in on this
uh but the look the baby yoda thing is
totally cool i've always liked the idea
of the mandalorians boba fett there's a
reason i've got boba fett my original
bow with that michael can you grab that
real quick and i show it to the people
i've got my original boba fett this is
my childhood boba fett
i keep them in a very special glass
container
this is my original boba fett i probably
got this
in you know 1982 i was maybe
four or five six something like that at
that point uh so that's boba fett
with red rocket that's not the rocket
that shoots out that i'm told it's worth
if you buy that thing it's worth like
five grand
this is just old school boba fett um
so so i always loved bob and there was
you know everyone loved boba fett right
like there was something mysterious
about this guy and then the prequels
when they explained that he actually
is the guy that you know was cloned and
django is
his dad but it's actually him um
mandalorian i need i need a little bit
more i don't know get a little dirtier a
little a little more violent maybe a
little grittier i sense we're gonna get
some of that stuff
um i i hope we do uh i hope we do but
you know what i'll take it though
it's it's bet it's better than a lot of
the last stuff that's come out and i'm
also not watching anything right now
i'm sort of just like are you guys
feeling this too like that there's just
like kind of nothing left on hulu or
netflix i'm just like tired of all let's
start some other show
with subtitles about a guy who has
problems like all right i got my own
problems man
like so i'm sort of over everything so
i'm literally just watching seinfeld
again at this point so i am looking to
looking forward to mandalorian tonight
all right guys have a great weekend
try to avoid the politics if you can get
out there enjoy yourself
obviously we have we have a really
really crazy week like joking aside
hyperbole aside and everything else it's
going to be a crazy week um the
aftermath no matter what happens you're
going to see people who got everything
wrong
turning on other people you're going to
see people who've got everything right
trying to destroy the people who got
everything wrong you see every version
of that i'm going to try my best
to uh to to make some sense of it
and i'm sure i will fail along the way
so hopefully you guys will keep me
honest
uh but thanks thanks for watching and uh
and if you want to catch me this weekend
we do some stuff on the weekends on
reubenreport.com but i am off
i'm off twitter all right have a good
weekend everybody